here now is mike pompeo former secretary
of state fox news contributor mr
secretary great to see you tonight
uh we said from the beginning and i know
you did as well that if this
administration was really serious about
crippling the russian war effort
they wouldn't be funding it through the
back door by continuing to do huge
business with china
laura thanks for having me on that
that's exactly right
not only are we funding it they've
stolen the intellectual property that's
the basis for those very semi-conductors
and microelectronics that you described
they stole them from places like south
dakota and north dakota the woman you
were just speaking to transferred it
dump it back here in the united states
and are now selling it to vladimir putin
so his war machine can continue to
expand and you know these are hard
problems but this administration has no
plan no strategy they're not willing to
confront the hard truth that it the
partnership that she xi xingping in
china calls unlimited he says we're
unlimited friends
they're unwilling to confront the
challenge that that presents and be
serious about this i promise you if an
american company was trying to buy an
agriculture piece of property near a
chinese military base in beijing it
wouldn't happen and yet we're naive we
are we are silly about the way we think
about protecting the american people and
we have to understand that the chinese
communist party it didn't come here for
a good benign noble purpose they came
here to conduct espionage and reduce the
capacity for the united states to stand
on its own two feet
mr secretary there is bipartisan support
as beth just said there is bipartisan
support for stopping this
so if republicans take back the house
uh we don't know what's going to happen
in the senate we're going to talk to dr
oz in a moment from pennsylvania
but if they take back the house they
have to stop this they have to start
stop talking about it and stop it
absolutely and they have the ability to
do it there's legislation now which
we're going to try and bring some
semiconductors back from china back from
taiwan back to manufacture here inside
the united states they can put language
in that very piece of legislation that
would prevent precisely the kind of
transaction that's taking place in north
dakota and or you should know this isn't
a one-off they are free to move about
the cabin they did the same thing with a
company called smithfield in kansas that
was making pork uh the chinese are doing
this all across the country we have to
stop and congress has the capacity to do
that
uh one to ten rating ten ten being the
best performance of biden and um the
middle east how do you rate biden's
performance mr secretary oh you know i
do my best to be generous did you say
one was best it's uh
if one is best this is a nine and a half
no one is this is performances
this is the worst performance by an
american president the middle east in
decades and decades it was truly
unfortunate makes us less safe
no that's the most important thing it's
not like that it's funny or the fist
bump it's makes us less safe mr
secretary thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else